[موسيقى]
في كرواتيا وتحديدا في البحر الادرياتيكي
1200 جزيره تنتشر عبر الساحل الذي يبلغ
طوله نحو
5800 كلم
القوارب الصغيره هنا خلقت رابطا ماديا
وروحيا بينها وبين السكان واعتمدوا عليها
في حياتهم بشكل كلي
بوستيرا سفينه صغيره عمرها خمسون عاما منذ
صناعتها لم تغادر هذا البحر مطلقا
فازت بميداليه من البحريه الكرواتيه
وابحرت لما يقرب من نصف قرن بلا كلل او
تعب مع توقف اجباري واحد اثناء حرب
الاستقلال
[موسيقى]
في كرواتيا التي لا يمكنها الاستغناء يوما
ما عن هذه القوارب لم تعد بوستيرا مجرد
ناقل بحري للبضائع والسكان لكنها تحولت في
نظر الاهالي الى معلم سياحي يستحق الزياره
كما لو انها نصب تذكري
هذا الجمال الساحر لهذه الجزر لم يشفع
للسكان بالبقاء فيها تنقل يوميا العديد من
الشباب من سكان الجزر الصغيره الى مدينه
حيث تتوفر فرص العمل هناك
[موسيقى]
وهي الجزر الماهوله الوحيده من بين 13
ارضا صغيره تشكل سلسله جزر الى فيتي
يسكنها نحو 600 نسمه فقط ويشكل مطعم
السفينه نقطه يوميه لتلاقي السكان
المغادرين الى الجزر
بوستيره حلقه الوصل بين سكان الجزر وكبرى
المدن وبفضلها يصل الطعام والبريد
والعناصر الاساسيه للحياه الى الجزر
الصغيره
[موسيقى]
لاقناع السكان بالبقاء هنا العديد من
العائلات تغلق منازلها سنويا وتنتقل الى
البر الرئيسي الامر التي يسبب بعض المشاكل
للسكان الباقين
[موسيقى]
في فصل الصيف لا يقتصر عمل بوستيرا على
النقل فقط العديد من السياح يتوافدون
عليها لتتولى عمليه نقلهم كي يستمتعوا
بجمال الجزر هذه السفينه الصغيره تعبر
السنين والعواصف والامواج بالوتيره نفسها
يوميا المتغير الوحيد طوال 50 سنه هو
البشر فقط
[موسيقى]